ragazzi vi ringrazio per avermi fatto
notare che si possono attivare i
sottotitoli su outlast perché non lo
sapevo e in questo episodio quando
registrato ancora non lo sapevo ma dal
prossimo di attivo quindi state
tranquilli
direi che possiamo riprendere giuro che
è passato qualcuno l'ho visto [ __ ]
chi cazzo è ciao
porca [ __ ] ragazzi non pensavo
sfondare la porta è bene bene mi sta
seguendo ancora chi cazzo ragazzi di
cazzo sta succedendo via di qui come sia
cui si apre porto dove andare a
domandare fatemi uscire di qui ragazzi
chi cazzo è quello è la porta si aperta
portasse faccia molta si porta già
aperta
apri apri quale edizione ma c'è un cazzo
sì sì sì sì dico non ci passa perché
obeso
se io peso punto stronzo non ci passi
mangia meno hamburger
ok si è offeso di brutto ed è meglio che
scappi prima che torni sono dove devo
andare a di qua di carico ammesso che di
qua non c'è ma perfetto ragazzo non un
genio nel trovare le vie ragazze sta
diventando tutto c'è un bottone rosso
voglio schiacciare il bottone rosso c'è
nessuno qui vero bene c'è un bottone
attiva le due pompe dei gas e
l'interruttore principale per avviare il
generatore by vi abbiamo che sono un
genio devo attivarle però prima è
intellettuale ragazzi c'è un tizio
appeso tanto per cambiare non vedo un
cazzo non vedo il senso senza la
videocamera non vedo niente
vabbè io apro le porte perché lohan tipo
queste mi sa che questa è una di sicuro
c'è nessuno bene così i ragazzi c'è quel
tizio che è bruttissimo
non c'è bisogno di usare la violenza con
i pulsanti non è che ti hanno fatto male
però vabbè l'altra penso sia dalla parte
opposta sicuro tipo qua oh di qua ci
sono arrivato ragazzi non mi ricordo chi
è questo ragazzi che cazzo succede
vieni qui vieni creditori no no no ma
[ __ ] dov'è accadrà
che cazzo ragazzi dove dove [ __ ]
cosa ti giri con una mazza da baseball
by negli stadi con quella
via di qui vieni qui a veloce veloce
veloce veloce veloce veloce ragazzi non
vedo un cazzo 2 sto andando non so
ha proposto si no devi chiuderti da
aiuto alla partita leva qualcuno
veramente scusami se ti chiudo la porta
in faccia non lo faccio di solito beni
boldini ragazzi dove cazzo siamo quello
sfonda la gara ma non ci non ci sono
nascondi visto cazzo di gioco quello
sfonda come cazzo fate ce la propone
valeva la le parole vale regola leva
capuana ma affanculo sto gioca pieno di
impartì maledizione senza neanche
volerlo chi fa i cazzi tuoi
mio dio non so dove sto andando salta mi
ricordavo che sono al tavolo ragazzi
devo aprire la porta andare a prima è
chiuso cup urbana che in parte
devo devo trovare devo trovare qualcosa
che non so come scappare lasko posta
raga ma qualcuno mi spiega dove devo
andare se questa fosse questa chiudi la
porta maledizione
ok forse ci siamo sì se figlio mio non
sfonda neanche qui vero vero caro sfondi
uno sfondo
mi sa che esporta il pezzo che cazzo
perché io parlo ciao sei bellissimo e
devo maledizione ma stai ferma questa
mazzo diving pilar tra nike a pranzi hai
capito
ci siamo dai a privati e no ma cazzo
torni e che mangi della sicura minchia
di nuovi indietro magari non mi ricordo
ancora sono arrivato
torna ai comandi della sicurezza cioè
devo tornare tutto indietro no ma
l'inizio sbagliato strada
buongiorno ragazzi dove dovevo andare a
domandare aiuto ho sbagliato strada di
carico di pazienti
se anche tu sei obeso anche tu sei obeso
ti giuro quella ammazza la puoi prendere
ma sai dove tela di rimettere madonna
santissima sarebbe con un altro rilancia
la videocamera nell'occhio e tornata la
luce raga ci siamo dopo gli allora
adesso devi fare tutto il casino dovrà
aprire le porte bene così allora ci
siamo la porta qua è sfondata [ __ ]
apriste innanzitutto tizio di prima non
so dove è andato che cos'è casa e giuria
che mi sto trovando è quello di prima
dio che sempre lo sto anche tu sei
bruttissimo anche tuo amico mio sembri
zio fester ragazzi uguale a zio fester e
lui zio c'è una squadra dello slot che è
entrata nell'edificio paranormal swat
ragazzi sta diventando ok
comunque tu dovresti devi entrare nella
famiglia addams perché non sei
autorizzato ad uscirne
mimì mi ha fatto piacere anche che mi ha
sedato si vede che mi voleva stare
tranquillo però non siamo forse questa è
la casa degli addams alla fine non lo so
dove cazzo sia io poi visto che bello
che poi mi sveglio non si sa dove questo
mi piace il suo gioco prima mente i
videogiochi in dio
lo dico sempre che che iniziano in posti
dove non si sa come ci sei arrivato
sto gioco è più o meno uguale solo che
durante il gioco ti svegli i posti dove
non se non sai come ci sei arrivato ma
bella videocamera ce l'abbiamo perfetto
io veramente non so che cosa rest in
peace resti in più ho capito lo devo
rimanere in pace al semi sedate mentre
sto a chiarendo i computer non posso
ciao bello tu sembri una persona grazie
grazie
3 cazzo sei andato
amico mio escono tutti i giorni vi do
non c'è bisogno che ti disperi così che
cazzo fa va bene se ci siamo risvegliati
in una prigione non hai da lì dove ci
siamo di come ci siamo finiti qui c'è
questo penso sia al posto dovergli
chiudevano i più malati di tutti e
giustamente hanno chiuso a me cioè non
c'erano alti
io non ti do una mano ti arrangi da solo
ciao senti io non vorrei entrarci dentro
ma che bello 6
bene così ragazzi allora vediamo di
uscire la sto posto in italia 1
ragazzi io io me ne vado di qua perché
sennò marocco ce l'ha più piccolo di te
va bene senti io non so cosa fa io non
scenderei qui sotto sinceramente non ci
voglio scendere ma mi sa che sono
obbligato se ti giochi fantastici
ragazzi questo è deve essere la nuova
sede leiber crombie sentite ragazzi io
ho avuto brutte esperienze con lui
quello si chiama spencer e non è un mio
amico ve lo dico senti tu fai infami un
favore smette a ritirare testate al muro
e ascolta mi senti fai il cazzo te vuoi
io ci ho provato
e vabbè bene cos'è mai così ragazzi
andiamo di testate anche noi così almeno
è mio sto muro prova che una tua [ __ ]
colonna ma vera che io concentrato
qualcuno prima comunque usa più
ok non è giusto non puoi affacciati così
a finestrini telo proibisco
ma v'è qua dentro non ci si può entrare
invece sì invece sì e qualcuno c'è anche
scavato un uscita e non so chi è quel
genio ma lo stimo voi tutti non ci
potete passare di correre che siete
troppo besio sì invece ragazzi possiamo
uscire di qua perché non ce la faccio
più
ricaricare le batterie si grazie bene io
io veramente non so dove stiamo andando
a finire ma al suo posto non mi è
piaciuto per niente c'è nessuno ok bene
così io ho chiesto ci sarà qualcuno non
mi hai risposto va bene senti io non ho
io non ho cercato di entrare qui dentro
con la mia volontà mi hanno costretto no
comunque io vorrei uscire di qui se
possibile grazie
c'è un tizio che arriva io me ne vado
dall'altra parte bene così ok le guardie
sono andate letteralmente a puntare per
salire su una sporgenza muniti verso di
essa ok penso che debba fare così oh che
bello ritornano a miss mi sembra di
giocare a prince of persia ragazzi
vabbè andiamo avanti io c'è sempre
no adesso non ti aiuto avevi solo da
svegliati prima
vabbè continua cosa fa perché adesso
stai correndo e good wife
segui le scie di sangue fino all'uscita
no io la seguì le energie ma mi sa che
sono costretto goda waste provide the
way for love the blob io se trovassi una
scritta con scritto seguì il sangue non
lo fare il nome
decontaminazione in corso non sono
sporco quelli di prima lo erano
va beh noi usciamo comunque salvataggio
in corso va bene c'è qualcuno qui sotto
no fantastico raga io voglio uscire di
qui il prima possibile a meno anche
ragazzi io sono arrivato qui con una
[ __ ] macchina avevo anche le chiavi
posto uscire volendo non solo trovarla
l'uscita sei tu che scrivi sul muro che
ha detto la mamma che non si può sì bene
scendiamo qui sotto perché tanto di
sopra dimmi che si apre chiudendo le
porte alle tue spalle rallenterà i tuoi
inseguitori e me ne sono accorto più
volte se devo essere sincero ma non è
servito a fermarli ma non importa
jesus altro ct a 5 non è ancora uscito
calmati vabbè senti io non ti piaccio tu
non mi piace non creiamoci a vicenda e
che cazzo top mamma mia ragazzi che
gente scontroso il suo posto di merda
cioè io non andrei mai in vacanza in un
manicomio mi sta seguendo no anno mi sta
seguendo a meno ragazzi se trovo mitra
sono cazzi suoi
vabbè chiediamo sta portanto quel tizio
non mi piace amico mio
siamo induista [ __ ] stanza che cazzo
sussurri va beh noi io longo su facebook
alla lazio continua a sussurrare
tranquillo io me ne vado tanto c'è un
tizio col manganello di là che mi
aspetta invece a te no cioè questi erano
erano pizzi non mi avvicino tranquillo
stai calmo solisti giuro che pio
l'estintore e te lo faccio ingoiare per
intero così altro che panini e mcdonald
comunque dicevo
bene così raga non chiudete mai le porte
in faccia alla gente ma in questi casi
potete farlo speriamo si randelli noah
vicenda sti due perché non so che fare
altrimenti aspettate un attimo voglio
vedere randellate via vicenda
maledizione mi sa che non loro che
perfetto non si cagano bene così
non è che mi sta seguendo anche qui
aiuto facciamo il cambio i due si io sto
dentro
facciamo così ciclista porta che li sta
portando stampata l'armadietto auto
bullismo voi così ci siamo ragazzi mi
sono nascosto voglio vedere se funziona
almeno un armadietto deve essere utile
non mi trova ragaini nascondigli sono
troppo stealth è l'amor del cielo
ragazzi stiamo scendendo nel macabro qui
e vi giuro non sapete quanto sia
sollevato si è rimasto sollevato dal
fatto che quel tizio non è arrivato fin
qua
bravo che non gli hai detto niente
guarda e ti stimo io non avrei fatto lo
stesso sappilo dov'è andato tra è
sparito cioè se ne se volatilizzato
spero sia salito lì sopra la lega come
faccio a dire a questa gente non posso
c'è il tizio qui va bene perché fermo
che i ragazzi ragazzi calmi calmi non
c'è non c'è ragazzi non c'è ce la
possiamo fare
ok ok sì se non c'è più ha sfondato
tutte le porte del mondo e si è
volatilizzato meglio così un bottone
violo premo anche se non so che cos'è
follow the blood seguì il sangue a
quella è la porta di primo ok devo
tornare indietro raga torniamo indietro
perché è altrimenti via di qui porca
[ __ ]
c'è qualcuno ovunque [ __ ] posto e il
tizio di praga non si sa come far
riapparire a scomparire è questo è
l'erede di houdini sono sicuro c'è ma
anzi aperta questa cazzo
non c'è nessuno a bell importante che
non ci sia nessuno
il tizio dico è sparito non è sparito
non è sparito stai calma calma calma
madonna mia ma perché cazzo vuoi da me
corre corre ma porca [ __ ] me la deve
dare le mazzate sono contento per il 23
luglio le mazzate e non è piacevole tra
sicuro ce la possiamo fare
aprista porta chiudi saporta ok fronte
chiuso decontaminazione bene così ok
perfetto si è aperto tutto c'è qualcuno
ha sì ci sono i due tizi di prima io
quel che il progetto che parlare così vi
faccia molto più paurosi mentre invece
mi fate ridere perché avete le orecchie
a sventola
e io non c'è una vecchia sventolaccia le
cuffie quindi è pupatello tutte e due
tra l'altro lega questo è il posto di
prima cioè di nuovo le prigioni del
manicomio dove riuscire a anzi tipo
sempre più in sofferti e ragga devo
andare dall'altra parte ci sono i due
tizi però non voglio andarci di mia
spontanea volontà ma lo faccio perché
l'unica [ __ ] zona dove posso ancora
andare lì che non è che mi consola più
di tanto se mi fate scherzi sono cazzi
vostri hanno chiuso la porta
meno male che è chiuso almeno quella
semi spuntavano all'improvvisa non cazzi
miei vi giuro
ok c'è ma questa fatemi capire una presa
per il culo perché c'erano due tizi che
prima li ho visti erano veramente belli
c'è qualcuno qua dentro da tanto non mi
interessa vado avanti
ok credo di sapere effettivamente dove
sono andati non voglio seguire il sangue
ma non si sa perché lo faccio ti serve
una chiave elettronica per aprire la
porta un'altra perfetto
torniamo indietro mi saranno ragazzi ce
l'avete la chiave elettronica vi giuro
non vogliono rompermi le palle so che
siete due belli
nudi ragazza e mezzo mondo che si sta
dando la pazza gioia questo posto non
voglio andare lì sotto chiave magnetica
grazie mille mi sento osservati simo il
suo posto devo andar via prima che
succeda qualcosa di brutto
la chiave magnetica cielo quindi non è
un problema non so dove sono andati gli
altri due tizi di prima ma sinceramente
non me ne frega un cazzo quindi
continuiamo ci diamo la porta prima che
entri qualcuno da dietro non ci tengo ok
secondo me non sfrutta qualcuno da
davanti devo correre esci passando per
le docce e c dove dovevo uscire
nevica ragazzi da erika buon natale a
tutti ma questa e pioggia e pioggia e
neve si capisce ma per ragazzi nevica se
siete contenti
ok effettivamente sono andato a finire
il tizio di prima ad ora far finire gli
episodi così che vi divora me lo stomaco
per sapere come continua ma non lo
saprete fino al prossimo episodio
comunque ragazzi 6 video è piaciuto il
tono al solito lasciato un commento mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook e come
non i video trovata una descrizione se
investiti iscrivetevi non ci rivediamo
nel prossimo video bene ragazzi
[Musica]